Let's put everything together now by looking at a trace
of an entire lookup. Now in the examples before, we didn't
get to see the full lookup hierarchy because we issued
a recursive query. But let's suppose we wanted to see every
step of the DNS lookup process. You can do this
by using the trace option in dig. Here you can see
exactly what we saw before, which is the local resolver.
In this case, issuing a query to a local resolver and
receiving a referral to an authoritative server
for dot which could be any of the
following. That query, lists an answer for the
.edu servers which subsequently issues a referral to
the servers that are authoritative for gatech. Which
ultimately reply with the appropriate a records as
well as the authoritative nameservers for gatech.edu. A
final interesting example explores how to map an
ip address. Back to a name, in
this case, we're ultimately looking for PTRrecord, which
the name corresponding to this ip address. But
first, what happens is we receive a special
referral when we ask the root servers about
this particular IP address. Instead of being referred
to a particular .com or .edu. We referred
to a special top level domain called inaddr.arpa,
which maintains referrals to authoritative servers
that are maintained by the respective internet
routing registries, such as ARN, RIPE, APNIC and so forth. So here we
see a referral to inaddr.arpa. Subsequently,
we see a referral to 130.in-addr.arpa corresponding
to the first octet of the IP address. Next when we ask errant
about 130.in-addr.arpa we receive another referral, which is to
207.130.in-addr.arpa. And because 130.207
is allocated to gatech.edu. Aaron knows that the appropriate referral
for this part of the address space is to DNS 1,
2, or 3.gottech.edu. Next we issue a query for the next part
of the octet. 7.207.130.inanter.arpa
corresponding to the first 3 octets. And now we actually get the PTR.
Because DNS3.gatech.edu knows the reverse mapping
between 130207.7.36 and the name for that IP address. So you can see
that the PTR records, or those that map IP
addresses to names, are resolved through a special hierarchy through
in-addr.arpa at the root. Followed by a walk through the
regional registries and ultimately, to the domains, such as gatech,
that are responsible for particular regions of the IP address space.